Entonces, pospusimos esa cirugía.
Mi pelvis rota y yo estábamos frente a 6 semanas en el sofá,
y me habría vuelto loca si no hubiera sido por mis amigos.
se organizaron fiestas espontáneas en mi casa todas las noches durante semanas.
Me alimentaron. Estaba entretenida.
Fue grandioso.
Pero ese tipo de entusiasmo es algo difícil de sostener a largo plazo,
y finalmente se redujo a solo un amigo,
que me enviaba chistes durante el día
y venía y me hacía compañía en las noches...
alguien que conocí mucho mejor durante este período de convalecencia.
Y cuando finalmente me unieron lo suficientemente bien
como para soportar peso,
cargamos un telescopio en el automóvil y nos fuimos a las montañas
para mirar el cometa Hale-Bopp.
Sí, somos geeks.
Y quedamos atrapados en un deslizamiento de tierra.
(Risas)
Lo sé, piensan: "¿en serio?"
No. Solo bromeo.
(Risas)
No más desastres. No. Justo lo opuesto, de hecho.
Eso fue hace 21 años,
y durante 19 de esos años,
He estado casada con ese maravilloso introvertido
que nunca en un millón de años se hubiera acercado a mí
bajo otras circunstancias.
Tenemos una maravillosa hija de 14 años,
que hizo todas mis ilustraciones
(Ovación y aplausos)
Sí.
Entonces, consejo profesional:
aparentemente, nada te hace más sexy que necesitar un andador
en tu primera cita.
Esta no es una historia sobre perforaciones
o tiburones o cocimientos o fracturas.
Es una historia de amor.
Es una historia de amor con un pequeño epílogo divertido.
Ahora estaba cargando peso otra vez, podría reprogramar esa cirugía,
sacar la espina.
Pero ya no lo necesitaba.
Resulta que cuando te rompes un hueso,
tu cuerpo elimina el calcio de todos los huesos de tu cuerpo
y de la pequeña espina de erizo de mar que te has alojado
en la articulación de tu dedo.
Entonces sí,
mi pelvis ahora es parte erizo de mar.
(Risas)
Así al cerebro biológico, cerebro físico,
cerebro de adrenalina, cerebro de mamífero de sangre caliente,
puedo agregar "cerebro de erizo"
con todas las superpotencias que eso confiere.
No hay que preocuparse:
que no sea completamente humana es una de las cosas
que mi familia ama más de mí
(Risas)
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)